IDOIA ORTIZ DE ARTINANO
GONI: So my name is Idoia.
I've been working with
Anjali Sastry for a year now.
In two independent studies,
actually, I did two.
I am in the class of
the Sloan Fellows '18.
I just graduated two weeks ago.
So when I came here to
Sloan, I was interested,
and I was super focused
on working in intersection
of government,
technology, innovation,
and entrepreneurship.
When I started
doing my research,
I realized that there was
a super interesting space,
that it's about the
startups doing work
in selling to governments to
improve the service delivery.
So my research, my
independent study,
has been focused on this space.
So to narrow the topic
of my independent study,
the key was the work
that I did with Anjali.
Actually, she helped me a lot.
And when you come here
to the university,
you have a lot of interests.
And everything is super broad.
You want to do everything,
and you can't in this kind
of independent study.
So having these kind
of conversations
every week, several hours
per week, helped me a lot.
So what I wanted to do
with my independent study
was a combination
of research to see
which was the academic
or these research
papers already made in the
market, in this market,
or in this specific space,
but also see and take
advantage of the connections
that you have here at MIT
to see what was going
on in the market.
So with Anjali, we
decided to create
what we call Public Tech
at MIT Series of speakers,
that it was a good excuse
for us to go out there,
say, OK, I'm doing
this research.
I'm doing these
lines of research
about these, these,
and these things.
But I want to know what you
are doing in this space.
So please, can you
come here to MIT
and explain us
what you are doing?
And I mean, that was amazing.
I don't think that no
one is coming nowhere
if you as a student go.
But if you go and
you say, I'm studying
what you are doing here at MIT.
They come.
So with this excuse,
we had several people,
super level people doing
super interesting stuff, that
came here to explain us
what they were doing.
And afterwards, we had the
opportunity, of course,
to take all that experience
and all that information
to put it, in my case,
in my research paper.
And that was amazing.
Here in Sloan, you
come, and suddenly, you
have an entire
ecosystem for you.
The challenge here is to
understand the ecosystem
and to know where is
your tribe of people that
are interested in
the same things
that you are
interested in and to be
super efficient with your time.
Because at the end of the day,
you have so many things to do.
So that combination
of good classes--
I mean like the state of
the art of many things
in these classes--
and this ecosystem on
opportunities to do
and action learning and to
have this kind of interaction
and debates and
conversations with people
that are already doing these
kind of things, it's amazing.
I don't think that
you will have these
in many other universities.
Well, I learned many
things during this process,
especially because I was
interested in something
super, super specific and
not necessarily very common
in this school.
So I was coming from
the public sector.
This is a business school.
But it still is a business and
administration school, right?
So in Australia, you have
also in the government.
So what I had the chance
with this independent study
was like to focus on a
specifically this space
that maybe I didn't have
too many chances or too
many opportunities to
work on in other classes
or in another events or whatever
that they had in the school.
So the structure, the
work, in independent study
is kind of complicated.
I think that it's the
most challenging thing.
Why?
Because at the end of the
day, you have a lot of classes
with a lot of a homework
and assignments due
tomorrow or yesterday.
So when you have these
independent studies
that you know that you have
the whole term to do it,
you are always having
other kind of priorities.
So for me, it was key to create
an outline from the beginning
and create a schedule
for that outline.
So at least I knew, and I
was tracking my performance
and my development.
And that helped a lot.
It's true that at
the end of the day
you take this last week that
you have at the end of the term
to focus or to create,
to edit, or to make
it the substantial thing
of the independent study,
but I think that I
did a very good job
of doing these all these
research and everything before.
I would say in the
first part of the term.
Talking about the
challenges that I
had when working my
independent study,
I would say that maybe in
my second independent study
that it was about,
as I said before,
taking a case, a
real case, and use
the research and the academic
content that I was studying,
apply it, and see
what could happen.
And so I started with,
let's say, with an idea,
thinking that that was
the right thing to do
and that it could work
in that specific context.
For a specific example there,
I was studying in Peru.
And when I went through
all the research,
I was realizing that it
was not going to work.
And that's super complicated
because it's a real case.
It's real people working
with a lot of engagement
and a lot of ideas or are super
positive about doing something
like that.
And I was seen studying
different cases,
studying the research done,
studying all the information
that I could get from
the MIT, that thing
that they were doing.
And I was studying.
It was not going to work.
So for me, it was kind of
struggling in the process
because I didn't want
to tell them that,
but I could not do it.
So I remember that I went
through all the process
of writing everything.
And at the end of the day, at
the end of the process, I said,
I need to put down
my recommendations
and hard recommendations.
Like saying, OK, so
there are some baselines
that you are taking from
random that are not OK--
blah, blah, blah, this kind of
things that it was kind of--
And I had a
conversation with them.
It was hard.
But you can see
there the real value
of the independent
study and the process
that you are doing, right?
At least I guess that--
I don't think that they are
doing any more this project
because the conversation that
we had because the research
that I did.
And that has value.
But it was hard.